so we're here with the MakerBot cupcake
C&C which is a 3d printer now you heard
me right it's a 3d printer so what that
means is that you're taking plastic and
you're building literal 3d objects so
the plastic is things like PLA which is
made out of corn and abs which is the
hard plastic that they make Legos out of
it now check out some of these objects
so you can build a wineglass hollowed
out beautiful card you can build let's
say you're playing foosball and you your
piece breaks or man breaks you can build
yourself an actual foosball guy soccer
player full-size full body to match the
one that you have in your kit
additionally you can build things like
Thom Yorke's head because he actually
open-sourced the data that was filmed
for a video of his so you can go online
to find the data for his head and print
an actual 3d version of Thom Yorke's
head and face
now the kits cost nine hundred and fifty
dollars which might seem a little bit
expensive but that's pretty amazing
considering it's a 3d printer now what's
also cool about it is that you're
building it but all the boards and the
electronics come fully assembled so
you're just kind of doing an assembly
line of the actual wooden pieces the
pulleys the gears and things like that
there's a couple hundred moving parts
which is actually not that bad now
what's also interesting about this whole
scenario is that there's a whole
thriving community of users who are
taking these to build all kinds of
different objects they're sharing the
objects online so the it's almost like a
competition but like a friendly
competition and additionally they're
sharing information on how to build and
in
prove upon the design everything is
completely open-source to the software
is open-source
the hardware is open-source so I think
you're gonna pretty much in the future
see a lot more of these kits getting
tweaked getting rebuilt
now the cupcake CNC is about the size of
a Mac classic which means that you can
only build objects that are small but in
the near future MakerBot is going to
release an even larger 3d printer which
means you're going to see even bigger
and bigger objects being built and I
just can't wait to see what people come
up with